do you even know what you were really
guarding here the real purpose of this
place you don't know do
there's an answer here to the question
no one's ever even dreamed of asking do
you want to see this is just a speck of
dust sitting on a much bigger hey
everybody we got brand new West world to
break down and it looks like we're going
to some of the other parks now Shogun
world is the most prominently featured
one but then there's this place that
looks like the real world in flashbacks
or in present day but that might wind up
being future world - because Dolores is
specifically talking about guarding this
thing in the trailer so the thing is
actually the island that is the park or
parks multiple because at the beginning
of episode one that person from the
Chinese military was coming off the boat
arguing with the Strand character about
who had jurisdiction your government
gave us sole control over what goes on
on this island so if you're brand new to
the channel I'm doing Westworld season 2
videos be sure to subscribe to get
everything
there's also a giveaway that I forgot to
announce during my episode 1 video last
night that I'll announce at the end of
this for Marvel stuff this week but
episode 2 is titled reunion the reunion
is obviously a hat tip for Maeve finding
her daughter but also for a reunion
between Dolores and young William like
he comes and talks to her with James
dello sexually the person who founded
the del o's company so this is an
unspecified amount of time after this
event with logan happened so we also see
logan in this new party scene and what
looks like either a future world or it's
on mainland china it's hard to tell
where they are because it kind of looks
like the real world but as a lot of you
theorized on my episode 1 video there is
a future world that's probably one of
these parks in the actual plot of the
future world movie so long ago was them
just replacing important world leaders
with duplicates so that actually might
be what Charlotte's doing it's
possible but that does feel kind of like
an obvious grab so I'm expecting a
little bit of a twist would you see how
much they pull from the classic movies
because there was only a little bit of
the original plot of the west-world
movie during season one the movie was 30
plus years ago there was a big revolt in
the movie it was all about the robots
just up rising and killing all the
guests so 30 plus years ago on the TV
show they referred to a big revolt so
that was sort of their way of
referencing the west-world movie like
this actually happened the west-world
movie exists within the continuity of
the TV show it's just that everything
that you're watching on the TV show is
happening many many years later in the
future within the spirit of reunion we
see that Logan is back he doesn't look
like he's trying to stab William or do
anything crazy like that so at some
point they have it out because you see a
picture of him with his father James
Dell oohs but you also see William
talking to him so it sounds like there's
some weird corporate maneuvering that
goes on behind the scenes in William
takes power over Logan because it
sounded like during season 1 Logan
expected to take over the company
but I love the way that James delos
looks at Dolores in this scene here of
her handing the can this was very
important for the man in black this was
really what set him off he got super
pissed off because Dolores didn't
remember him after that huge adventure
that they had they kind of pushed him
off the deep end even though he was
already headed in that direction so
it'll be interesting to see what young
William is doing now because we know
what the ban of black is like at the
beginning of season 1 so he's on that
path but man in black and present-day is
sort of headed in a reverse direction
it sounds like part of the idea of the
door the game that he's playing has
something to do with helping Dolores
escape the park and because all these
hosts you know in the two-week period in
the future are dead in the lake it might
be that she's one of the few people that
make senator Park this season but I
don't think that this is necessarily
confirmed to be the very end of the
season this might just be in the middle
of the season or they could be doing
that thing where the entire season takes
place over a two-week period because
when we pick up at the beginning of
episode 1 it's basically the del O's
company coming to rescue everyone but
then we learn in the flashbacks right
after they begin that journey and
tonight revolt that Charlotte radios
them and they say we're not going to
come rescue you until you give us that
Abernathy robot it might just wind up
being a backup like a hard copy of all
the code that they need to continue
operating the part they might have just
been worried that he was gonna wipe
everything so he could just be like the
hard drive that they need to grab so
that they can just keep doing all these
normal things day to day but he hit this
really cool shot of what looks like the
construction of a memory cord this might
be their cortex or something similar
like the way that they store information
inside those little devices that they
plugged into the tablet the Shogun world
stuff isn't supposed to be in a ton of
episodes this season but obviously mave
grabs the samurai sword so it looks like
she's gonna be interrogating some of the
other hosts they're looking for her
daughter I am kind of wondering what
time period Delores is in when she's
talking to Barnard here if this is
present day when she's wearing the black
dress because this green grab is of her
wearing her Wyatt gear talking to him so
just remember that you know two-week
period some of this is happening at the
end of that two-week period some of it
is happening at the beginning of the
two-week period I'm guessing that Wyatt
Dolores is at the beginning of that
two-week period right after the revolt
starts and then this when she's wearing
the black dress might be at the end of
that when she's preparing to leave the
park you see the del O's people in
present day chasing down Clementine
remember she got lobotomized so it'll be
interesting to see what her character is
up to or if they just use her as a trap
because you see this giant explosion
here so it might be just like that
episode one trap where it's like oh
thank god we're saved but nope the hosts
are laying traps for all the Della's
people the man in black looks like he's
gone back to that outlaw town remember
how they rescued the outlaw Logan was
like no no don't turn him in he'll take
us to his boss that actually wound up
being Clifton Collins Lauren's character
of this really crazy outlaw town where
all the suppose at Easter eggs and
really awesome stuff was gonna happen
like Logan was super excited to go there
oh it's way more fun there but it just
seems like he's continuing to retrace
his path of some of the most significant
areas that young William went to during
season one he did cast a couple of big
actors for the ghost nation storyline so
like most of the time when we see their
characters they're just standing there
looking really badass not saying
anything but it does sound like this
season they intend to give them some
dialogue so
get tied up in Dolores's revolt oh
they'll be talking to the Dell O's
people will see which story light they
show up during the only real big WTF
from the original trailer that I don't
spot footage from in this trailer is
Bernards copies so there's like a
picture of Charlotte looking at all the
Bernard hosts so at some point she finds
out but remember all the Charlotte stuff
that we saw during episode 1 is taking
place two weeks in the past right after
the revolt starts and then all the stuff
with Bernard on the beach where he's
like oh my god I killed them all or
we're like strand in the devas people
show up that's two weeks in the future
and Charlotte is nowhere to be found so
at some point something might wind up
happening to her but just post all your
theories in the comments below they
talked a little bit about the drone host
to how they're basically just like the
hosts made to look like they would
naturally look if you didn't care if
they look human so instead of doing them
as CG or like actual animatronics they
just have like really tall really thin
people inside latex costumes walking
around but I love how freaky they are
the cool thing about this storyline is
is that there's all kinds of stuff that
it seems like Charlotte knows about that
nobody else knows about so there'll be a
bunch of surprises through her storyline
like surprise there's a secret plot that
we teased last season that nobody knew
about we're messing with the DNA of all
the guests there's also a bunch of stuff
that Bernard probably knows that nobody
else knows because he worked with Ford
one-on-one for so long then you have to
remember that Dolores is one of the
original hosts so she knows everything
since the beginning of the park as she
says during episode one I remember
everything I've seen the future that's
probably a reference to future world 2
which is probably one of the other parks
but remember they said that there's at
least six parks we know Shogun world is
one of the other ones so I'm hoping that
we get to visit most of the others this
season I don't know why they would tease
six and then not show you all six during
the season obviously I'll post my
episode 2 video next Sunday night but
because I forgot to name the infinity
war ticket giveaway winner Adrienne
Martinez because you live in Los Angeles
and you are one of the people that
commented that you wanted the ticket you
were the winner for that marathon
hopefully this works out but when you
see this please private message meet
your contact information so we
arrange for you to pick up the ticket
I've also tried to track you down
because it's on Wednesday so this is
kind of short notice but no worries
there's all kinds of other giveaways
going on this week too in my normal
videos so click here for my episode one
Westworld video and click here for brand
new marble thank you so much for
watching everybody to stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]